hacker mode is battlefield hardlines
replacement for the previous games
commander mode given hardlines cops
versus criminals focus you're not going
to be dropping cruise missiles on
people's heads as the hacker instead
you'll be taking over cameras and
providing intelligence to your teammates
while disrupting the enemy by setting
off gas systems and jamming their GPS
signals you can view the action from a
map perspective a top-down perspective
or by looking over the shoulder of any
squad leader plus you've got some cool
abilities let's take a look at each one
and explain how best to use them hacking
lets you take control of objects in the
map like cameras gas systems and power
transformers hacking a camera will cause
it to automatically spot enemies in its
view distance for the rest of your team
revealing them on everyone's mini-map
you can also look through the camera
yourself to get a better angle of
interior locations something your
traditional top-down view wouldn't
usually allow take over as many cameras
as you can as early as possible and your
team will have eyes on most of the map
before you've even cracked the vault gas
systems and transformers can be hacked
so that they automatically explode when
an enemy is near stunning and
disorienting them they'll need to
recharge for a short time after
exploding so only hack these when you're
ready to coordinate movements with the
rest of your team
GPS spotting is like a UAV that reveals
enemy positions in a small area on the
map for a short amount of time
use this as often as possible in areas
where your hacked cameras can't already
see GPS jamming acts as a kind of
counter for GPS spotting hiding your
teammates position in an area and
preventing them from being spotted if
you don't want the enemy to know which
way your team is breaking into a vault
from in heist mode drop a jamming signal
over their point of entry the
traceability scans the entire
battlefield to show high-value targets
like enemies spawn beacons and squad
leaders on the map you can then give
orders to your own squad leaders to
attack these targets it's also a great
way to point out the locations of pesky
snipers at the edge of a map one ability
the hacker can use on their own
teammates is the squad upgrade this
increases the rate at which that squad
receives reputation perks
basically reward like extra armor or
grenades that only exists for that match
use this like a carrot for squads that
are being good and following your orders
fast deploy is another ability you can
use on one of your own squads it reduces
the time it takes for members of that
squad to reform this is really useful
for squads who are leading the charge in
heist mode and are expecting to take a
lot of casualties very quickly
finally overclock is an ability to have
replies to themselves to reduce the
cooldown time of their other abilities
the catch is some abilities may overheat
making them unavailable for a short time
it's a randomized risk but if you're
waiting for everything to cool down
there's no harm in using it with these
abilities battlefield hardlines hacker
mode plays like a smaller scale tighter
and more focused version of the prior
command emotes its most useful in
hardline heist mode where situational
awareness is crucial and least useful in
Hotwire mode where everyone's too busy
getting in car chases or flipping
choppers you're rarely going to get to a
top of a leaderboard playing a full
match as the hacker so just do it as a
favor for your team besides you can
switch back to a regular infantry role
mid game but the reward in seeing your
fellow criminals get away with bags cash
as the pursuing cops are caught in a
cloud of gas it's worth it
you